make way for one of the greatest
shooters in the history of mankind
when James Naismith went up on that
ladder with that peach basket he didn't
know that there'd be a little guy in
Riverside California lanky guy weighed
about a hundred and seventy pounds he'd
be one of the greatest shooters ever
Reggie Miller joins us now Tech is in
and you're giving me way too much credit
170 when I was in Riverside I was more
like 145 150 when you who recruited you
aside from UCLA what other big schools
there was two choices that it came down
to other than obviously UCLA Arizona
State coach Doug Collins was an
assistant coach there included me hard I
was very close to going there and
Florida State now remember back in the
day Florida State was a powerhouse with
Leon Wood and poppy and those guys like
that so those were the two schools but
as a kid growing up in Southern
California
everyone always wanted to play obviously
for UCLA how's that voice are you ready
for this March Madness of course I'm
ready okay so reg we'll be in Tulsa it's
pretty this time of the year in tulsa
ok's a lot prettier than what's coming
your way all right
I know but all of us get to be together
in a hotel room so that's what's fun
about that well look this is I we said
this last last week to me this is the
most favorite time of the year for me
because it's right after the all-star
game the ending the NBA players they see
the light at the end of the tunnel
because the intimacy's and the players
are beginning you've got spring training
and you've got the greatest tournament
ever in March Madness one-and-done if
you have a bad shooting night if your
best player tweaks an ankle if you don't
crash the board you can be going home so
this year I have 10 to 15 teams that
legitimately could win this game I will
get to those in a moment let me give the
formal introduction so reg will be
calling Baylor New Mexico State on
truTV SMU versus the winner of
Providence and USC will you be nice to
us see if they win and you're calling
the game you being a UCLA Bruin
apologist I had you USC last year and it
was no issue I have no no Clark I have
no problem with that of course I love
Andy infield okay and the Trojans yeah
we had him when he was a Florida Gulf
Coast great coach I love the system yeah
I have no problem okay I have a little
bit very little the head of Trojan blood
because if Cyril D okay yeah Kansas
versus the winner of nc central UC Davis
on TNT than Miami versus Michigan State
on on TNT more pain how about that
second round potentially if you can get
coach izzo versus coach South self yeah
it's pretty coming Kansas versus
Michigan State is probably as good as a
kid I know this you know at 19 and 14
it's not the typical Michigan State you
know team or system but doesn't it
always seemed that Coach Izzo and his
team's always rise this time of year
yeah in the tournament yeah absolutely
more fun to play college or the pros
personally for me the pros I mean you're
playing at the highest level obviously I
just loved you know competing against
you know the best players in the world
let's take a challenge I'm just talking
about pure fun how much fun did you have
at UCLA as opposed to put it to you this
way
I stayed all for you nothing like that
college life and look just being able to
walk the campus of UCLA and you know the
fans and the people yeah definitely
college life it was pretty sweet and you
got paid well at UCLA so that they used
to but not when you got there
like look Walt Hazzard wasn't having any
for me nor do I know what happened after
me all I know is from my floor
years it was straight by the book and
that's how it's always been and you're
still bitter about that now no names
attached to it rich recruited were you
offered anything when you're recruited
hey you feel like no in other schools no
here look this is an all honesty because
I come from a military background Saul
wasn't happy he was not playing around
yeah okay because of that military
background he played everything by the
books because that's what government
officials do and no we weren't having
any oh no no no nothing
your dad Vera better call Saul before
the show better call Saul yeah if I said
you could watch Duke or UCLA you had to
pick between the two come on are you
really well I know you love UCLA but is
Duke more interesting I'm talking about
entertainment value if I take away
personally no I'm gonna go with UCLA if
you're not asking me of course Duke is
they've got the hollow Penn coach and
Coach K and yeah I think universally yes
now I I love watching UCLA play Duke is
fascinating because you're never quite
sure what's gonna happen and it could
happen with that that team with Grayson
Allen is well thrown in there
I love Tatum I think Tatum is an
unbelievable talent there but the Lonzo
ball Steve Alford Bryce Alford teed
right Malik lows there between those two
of the most fascinating teams to watch
in the tournament for me they have a
great offense it's up and down they
shoot a lot of threes their defense is
starting to round in the shape and any
time you attach freshman phenom to
anything to launch a ball and then you
gotta you know obviously a little bit of
the drama with the dad you know saying
this I mean that draws attention to your
program so that's why people want to
tune in and watch but it's a fun brand
of basketball to watch Duke along the
same way they should a lot of threes and
but it's more so the winning why people
watch Duke and what a run they had
during the ACC tournament
to win it pretty crazy couple of things
MBA wise though you had the Golden State
Warriors sit there their starters on
Saturday against San Antonio here we go
again with this Jeff Van Gundy said once
again the fans are told you don't matter
pay us upfront we'll take your money and
then we'll give you whatever product we
want to is that a fair assessment it is
I'm a little disappointed because being
an old school guy I don't want to be
that you know that type of player if
they say we we never did this but it has
happened
and I'm sure the Commissioner is going
to have to address this you know when
the season is over because you are
gypping the fans because this was
supposed to be a marquee matchup now on
San Antonio side you couldn't help it
there's injuries getting a concussion
protocol for Kawhi and an irregular
heartbeat for LaMarcus so there's
nothing really you can do on their side
but for a little Stevie to sit but then
again we don't know what's going on
behind the scenes maybe Steve is looking
at his team losers of four or five I
believe and they look fatigued maybe
they need this break ok I know you lose
durant but they didn't have durant the
previous years before that and they
seemed to do well what do you say well
Kevin III yeah III know that the the
bench was different but I don't
understand this where you hit a reset
button and and I don't know you you'll
know obviously better than me but it
feels like the offense changes because
now everything is going through Steph
again so you have to go back to years
ago when they ran their offense through
him as opposed to you know the Durant
portion of the equation which is not
there for the next couple of weeks but
when you were running the offense
through Steph you had a better good
support yeah to accommodate that you
don't have that anymore you know because
you had to hemorrhage everything you
know to get KD but look let's just wait
until Katie gets back to see what we see
if he's a hundred percent if he's 90
percent if he's 75 percent because
that's going to tell a lot come playoff
time but to
because they had to give up so much of
their bench and they got a lot of young
guys with little experience other than
you know Livingston and Andre Iguodala
other than those two guys your bench
it's really spare so it's going to be
interesting to see what they do come
playoff time but if Katie comes back and
he's 90% to me there's still the
favorites
Larry Sanders just agreed to a two-year
deal with the Cavaliers so he's been out
of the league for two years and he's
going to take the spot of Andrew Bogut
so nice pick up I mean this is a guy
that could block shots he could be a rim
protector he's athletic but he's been
out of the game for a while um so it's
gonna be interesting to see how his
timing is well he's gonna be rested reg
he'll be rested well yeah we'll levy in
game shape you gotta remember we've got
what almost less than 20 games left I
mean this is a sprint to the finish line
and he's got to get caught up quickly
can you explain what Andre Iguodala was
talking about after the game Steve Kerr
said the media got Andre I have no idea
dropping the n-word he's talking about a
master and after I heard the interview I
really have no idea I really can't
explain it because Andre is a very smart
guy
really smart and it's hard for me to say
that from a guy's I went to Arizona but
he's a very intelligent young man look
listening to it there seem to be some
sense of sarcasm in there but look it's
hard for me to explain that you know
there's no excuse to you know they drop
the n-word when you're in a public
setting when you know you have
microphones around you I mean you hear
it all the time in the locker room on
the plane on the bus but you know in a
public setting or forum but again it's
hard for me to explain yeah and then
Steve Kerr said the media got underage
so the
Steve's been around it or seen it or
heard it before but now all of a sudden
well the media was really thinking that
he was taking a shot at Steve and he was
kind of letting them know that he does
this all the time that he got y'all and
y'all fell for the bait basically okay
how many teams you got winning at all
okay remember last week we said how many
sheets do you fill out yes and I said
three one your first see that you first
do that's the one that your heart is
that's your heart so I've only filled
out one so I'll just tell you my final
four no one over she's gonna shock you
UCLA Notre Dame Notre Dame North
Carolina Kansas no UCLA I have UCLA
losing to Kentucky now remember you
silly be Kentucky earlier this year
sucking at Kentucky so I just think it's
tough for a team on the neutral court to
win twice so that's the only reason why
I don't have to UCLA beating that's
because they beat them before there's
your name huh
I have Notre Dame have a few upsets this
is my very first one so this is my gut
this is what my gut is telling me a
surprise run s/m you
I have SMU playing Villanova and
Villanova I have SMU in the Elite Eight
good defensive team okay and that's
what--when and they have good guard play
[Laughter]
we've been talking about these you don't
have to know any names of any players in
the tournament all you got to do is just
throw it a couple of lines couple of
cliches and it sounds like you know what
you're talking about
[Laughter]
you know they they score the ball reg
they score guard play they got you can't
even say senior leadership there are no
more seniors in basketball
now I try to go with upperclassmen but
it sounds so like stiff so I go with the
the guards regard play reg is NBA duties
on hold while he takes part in March
Madness with Turner small March March
Madness all right when you're going to
Tulsa you going Thursday Wednesday
Thursday is that all day you know when
you watch all 18 which I'm so excited
about so I will get to Tulsa Wednesday
afternoon Thursday all day and start
Friday start body you'll be there with
Kevin Harlan Dan Bonner Dana Jacobson
covering the tournament in in Tulsa
I am excited tell Daniel tell Dan Bonner
I said allo I did a couple of games with
him and he couldn't have been more
helpful to me because I had no idea what
I was doing back at the mothership and I
did a few games with Dan Bonner and he
helped me he held my hand through some
games doing play-by-play I'm not quite
sure there's a better college basketball
analyst and admin or guy that's been
around a long time and he really knows
his stuff so we're very fortunate and
honored for him to to join us though
this is gonna be fun I think this is our
third season together with mr. Bonner
and it's gonna be so much fun a great
ride safe travels is always reg and
thanks for joining us Theodore you know
I love you right mm sometimes
Reggie Aloysius Miller the third he'll
have NBA on TNT after March Madness but
to he'll be in Tulsa the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience